hi I'm Paul Katz at the University of
Massachusetts Amherst and I'm gonna be
presenting as part of a team about the
burger brain project this is the team
approach to understanding whole brain
control of state dependent motivated
behaviors and it's funded by the brain
initiative from NIH so we want to
understand how individual neurons
interact to produce behaviors we are
what also want to understand how these
interactions change on the different
behavioral States and finally we want to
understand the complex dynamics of the
entire brain to do this we're going to
be using the neuter bank
Burgie estefanía which is shown in this
image but let me give you a little bit
of an introduction before that so large
brains evolved independently in both
mammals and mollusks humans and and
other mammals have fairly large brains
compared to other animals and so do
octopuses within the mollusks octopuses
and cuttlefish and squid have large
brains neuter banks have brains that are
related to octopuses but they're not
nearly as complex and allow us to
understand the cellular mechanisms of
behavior better neuter banks of course
are diverse and beautiful here's a slide
showing just a small number of the
species that are found in the oceans
around the world the one on the bottom
left is Tritonia daya media and it's
been studied for more than three decades
now initially by Dennis willows at the
University of Washington here he is in
is not as a graduate student but with
his grandchild neuter pranks are useful
because they have very large neurons
that are individually identifiable so
this orange circle at the top is a
neuron c1 as you can see from the scale
bar it's over 200 microns in diameter
this white neuron right here is neuron
c2 and you can see it this is an
unstained preparation just looking at
the brain sitting in a dish and you can
recognize of course the contralateral
counterparts of these two neurons there
are also neurons that could be
recognized by their neurotransmitter
content so inside the circle or three
neurons
which are called the DSis and if we stay
in the brain with an antibody against
the neurotransmitter serotonin they show
up very nicely as does neuron c1 but as
you can see neuron c2 does not contain
serotonin and so it doesn't show up with
this immunohistochemistry now having
neurons that are individually
identifiable allows us to work out
neural circuits with cellular precision
so this is work that again has gone on
since the 1960s initially by Dennis
willows then by the Peter getting and
then by Bill Frost and myself we have
identified a number of neurons that go
from sensory all the way to motor and
underlie the swimming behavior of the
species so if we look at a movie showing
Tritonia escaping from a predatory sea
star you can see that it basically flops
back and forth dorsally and then
eventually and this so called swim is a
nice easily repeated behavior so it is
elicited in the laboratory and it can be
elicited from a brain and a dish so here
again is the behavioral sequence that
you saw the on the bottom left of the
Tritonia escaping from the c star in the
middle is the brain and at the right is
the neural circuit controlling that
behavior we can complete we can put nert
sorry we can put electrodes into neurons
into individually identifiable neurons
and record the pattern of activity that
occurs during the swim motor pattern so
the three traces that you see are
recordings from C to D si + V si the D
si is the dorsal Simon Turner on the V
si is the ventral swim into neuron and
each spike is an action potential you
can see that the behavior then consists
of alternating dorsal and ventral bursts
and dorsal and ventral swimming -
neurons that correspond to the dorsal
and ventral flexions of the body the
whole behavior episode lasts about a
minute we can leverage what we
understand in one species to study other
species of neuter banks so here is a
photo micrograph of the brain with a
cell that we didn't talk about yet swim
one it's called and it has a particular
Anatomy and neurotransmitter content the
three green cells are the DSis that I
just spoke about and then the purple
cell is is si one we can find these same
neurons in numerous species of neuter
banks they have the same Anatomy they
have the same neurotransmitter content
the same relative position to each other
so these are homologous neurons and we
can then study their roles and behavior
we can plot the the swimming behavior we
can map the swimming behavior onto the
phylogeny of neuter banks so we see that
Tritonia which is a dorsal ventral
swimmer evolved swimming independently
from another dorsal ventral swimmer
plural brain Kia and that the yellow
species pallab lena dendron otis mela be
all swim with left-right body flexions
instead of dorsal body inflections the
nonetheless these species have the same
sets of homologous neurons so we can go
from species to species and look at what
the roles of these neurons are and what
we found is that they have different
behaviors they have sorry different
functions regardless of the swimming
behavior that is the same neuron as
present but it has different functions
in different species that have different
behaviors so the fundamental concepts
that we've advanced using this using
neuter banks is that rhythmic motor
patterns can be understood in terms of
the properties of neurons and their
synapses that neural modules are actions
of serotonin can be intrinsic to a
neural circuit and that homologous
neurons can have different functions in
different species but we've had
technical challenges electrophysiology
is limited to studying a small number of
neurons at a time working out the
circuitry with pairwise intracellular
recordings is just not scalable to a
brain of any size these brains have
4,000 to 10,000 neurons we can't
identify neurons without the behavior or
known marker so if we went to a species
that doesn't swim how would we identify
swim into neurons and knew to banks
themselves are difficult to obtain the
specimens are wild-caught and most
species can't be raised in the lab
so solution is to find an amenable
laboratory species leverage the
knowledge from other species and then
apply high throughput techniques that
get around the single-cell recordings
that we've been doing in the past so
we've started working on this species
Berga stefania because it can be reared
in the lab and i want to point out that
this was a project that was begun by an
undergraduate in my laboratory when I
was at Georgia State University Amira
Hirst
she found that we could easily raise
these species in the lab that they go
from eggs to back to adults in in less
than two months and they have a number
of features that you'll see from their
alliances talk that make them amenable
for developmental studies furthermore
they eat a sea anemone that we can also
raise and that's another problem with
new to banks is that they are generally
eating nidaria that are themselves
difficult to raise in the lab but these
sea anemone are pests and they grow very
readily
so the Bergy a brain project overcomes
the species overcomes a number of the
limitations of other neuter banks but
the thing is Berkey hasn't been studied
previously so we're starting off we have
this planted and characterised behavior
and determine the neural mechanisms of a
species that nobody has looked at before
I'm using high-throughput technology
this requires collaboration and hence
the brain initiative project we started
this project just over two just over two
years ago starting from zero on a
species that nobody's studied before and
the plan then is to identify the neurons
in the brain to describe and quantify
reproducible behaviors to record from
neurons during those behaviors to get a
complete connectivity map of the brain
all of the synaptic connections and to
mathematically and statistically
describe the brain network in activity
and then to create genetic tools that
moved it to move discovery forward sober
Ghia as I said has a mezzo scale brain
with large identified neurons as we
identify alone Iran so as we saw with
Tritonia so here's a picture of the
brain the eyes are actually right on the
brain as is the status ist's at the top
of the Rhine of four ganglion that that
contained the inputs for the
there's the chemosensory apparatus this
is the brain after it's been staying
with antibodies against two
neuropeptides small cardio active
peptide SCP and former from it which is
a phenylalanine methionine arginine
phenylalanine peptide on this is work
that was done by an undergraduate in my
lab at UMass my mine you end you can see
very clearly that there are the same
neurons present on the left and the
right sides they were in very
reproducible places so we can begin to
identify these neurons and give them
names we are using other types other
techniques in collaboration with Joe
Bergin at UMS and his student Joe Dwyer
postdoc in my lab does Ramirez has been
using light sheet microscopy combined
with clarity clearing technology to look
at the brain in situ in the animal so
I'm see the Rhino philia that lead up to
the olfactory organs the cerebral plural
ganglia the eye and the pedal ganglia
sitting on top of the esophagus and
buccal mass so this is what the ganglion
looked the ganglia look like in 3d
looking through an animal that's intact
here's a stack of images taken with the
light sheet microscope showing the
individual neurons this is just
intrinsic fluorescence and you can see
this small circles here we're going to
the Rhino four ganglia now and will
circle back in a second you can see now
there the the neurons that are coming
through you can see some of the fiber
tracts and the neuro pill regions right
there is a comma sure there's a few
white cells that stand out and those are
probably catechol and the nergic
autofluorescence here's just a look at
the people ganglion again you can see
the cell bodies on the outside the neuro
pillow region on the inside as well as
in the nerve tracts that connect the
brain to the rest of the body I wanted
you to take a look at notice that there
is a white cell that pops up at the
beginning of this feed right there
that's those actually one at the
beginning of one at the end those are
two probably again quatre colon and
nergic neurons that chain that have
autofluorescence with this fixation
technique
so one of the other techniques that that
Joe Bergin and Joe Dwyer have higher
pioneered is the use of magneto
hydrodynamic force to drive antibodies
and other charged particles in solution
into the bent of the brain so that by
applying both a magnetic force and an
electrical field at the same time they
the video on the right shows that even
Diane's solution is getting forced
through very quickly and that allows us
to stain in situ in the animal ganglia
and neurons so here is a 3d rendering of
the PETA ganglion stained with an
antibody against serotonin and again
this is a image of the ganglion in
position in the body stained with an
antibody against serotonin so we can now
begin to map all of the neurons in the
brain
and I give them names and form atlases
based on their location the
neurotransmitter content and their
neuroanatomy next we want to describe
and quantify reproducible behaviors so
this is an image showing a Bergy and
navigating towards a black stripe in the
distance on the edge of the tank
it doesn't reproducibly if you look at
the picture of the animal at the bottom
you can see that it has this little tiny
spot for an eye in fact there's only
five photoreceptors in that eye and yet
it can reproducibly navigate to a black
stripe we think that it's doing that in
order to find shelter if the animal is
fed it will go towards the black stripe
but if it's hungry it will continue to
scavenge in the middle of the tank the
animals also use they use olfaction to
find prey when they are hungry so the
the large rabbity are like things coming
out of the top of the animal are the
Rhino fours these are chemo sensory
organs the animals can perform a t-test
with nearly 100% accuracy or Y test when
you have their Rhino four is intact but
if you take off a single Rhino for then
they no longer perform the task and of
course they can't do with no rhino force
either so they are making comparisons
between the left and right Rhino for its
it's determined where
is located and this is again a task that
they only do when they're hungry so we
found that Bergy alok emotes to shelter
when it's sated and locomote stew food
smell when it's hungry and the goal then
is to understand the generations of the
generation of these behaviors in terms
of the activity of identified neurons
with known connectivity so I wanna hand
this over now to Bill Frost who will
talk about how to record from these
neurons during behavior hi this is Bill
Frost I'm at rosalind Franklin
University were a component of this year
one project and our goal is to record
from neurons during behavior in this
animal to do this we use fast voltage
sensitive dyes and we record as many
neurons as possible typically just to
show you what I'm talking about this is
a sharp electrode recording on the lower
of those two traces of the single neuron
and above it is an optical recording
using voltage sensitive dyes and you can
see that the dye traces out the action
potential quite well we've done this in
a number of mollusks and those are shown
in the bottom there primarily by works
but on Tritonian aplia but now we're
focused on fur via the context of this
project to get started I wanted to just
describe what we're doing here and what
the equipment we're using where this is
not a camera and a fluorescence type of
approach this is a 464 channel
photodiode array with this vast
voltage-sensitive dye so we typically so
far we take the brain out of the animal
pin it out in a dish we stay in the
brain with all the sensitive dyes that
enables the neurons to flicker in
brightness as they fire action
potentials then that we position a
photodiode array shown in panel B we
focus the image of that preparation if
the imaging aperture of the photodiode
array and that aperture is shown in
panel C right there you can see 464
photo diodes panel D shows the
preparation of ganglion projected onto
that imaging aperture and panel a shows
the example of raw data that we collect
now the raw data have to start with some
diodes seen many neurons and and some
neurons represented on many diodes so
the red and the green you can see there
are several diodes
or one neuron this bursting and some of
the guys in the green for another neuron
this bursting so that we need to do
spike sorting of this data we use an
unsupervised approach using independent
component analysis the basic collects
all of the signals from a given neuron
no matter how many diodes it's on and
puts them into one single neuron trace
and that's what you can see to the right
and the red trace and that's what you
can see to the right in the green trace
so we end up with in just a few minutes
after collecting the data a set of
single neuron traces from whatever we
record it now one thing I wanted to
point out at the beginning is that yes
we can record from a lot of neurons that
we can also identify many of the neurons
that we've known from prior laborious
sharp electrode studies so the upper of
the two photographs is a Tritonia brain
with the ganglia labeled if you look
closer in the lower photograph we've got
an arrow pointing to the neuron see two
that fall cats that just mentioned and
two of the dias eyes that also mentioned
those are members of the pattern
generator the panel a in the upper
middle or sharp electrode recordings
typically from papers you might see of
these three neurons and bursting in
there in a five cycle swim motor program
paddle B shows an optical recording of
the same region and we can see c2 all
three of the D sis in this case another
cell vs ia which is also in the pattern
generator and several other neurons
including some bursting neurons we
didn't even know existed until we made
this optical recording so you can record
from identified neurons and identify
them in the optical recordings and then
in panel C shows a recording from the
pedal ganglion where we've got a hundred
and forty seven neurons shown there in a
five cycle swim motor program so you can
record a lot of data it certainly beats
the sharp electro recording technique
that we've been using so long before
this but one of the great things about
optical recording is that you can look
at an area you're not familiar with and
immediately find cells of interest so
like Maria everything is areas we
haven't looked at before this is this is
an example from Tritonia our first
recording from the ventral side of the
cerebral gangland we recorded in panel a
to bursting urine in the motor program
we poked it with a sharp electrode later
on in the prep and found that bursting
neuron amongst a field of Don bursting
neuron in panel B we show we discovered
in
another prep a brand new set of bursting
neurons and the motor program shown to
the right in b2 and we poked during that
during the optical recording the next
optical recording in that preparation
one of them to show and further identify
it as a unique individual that we had
not been familiar with and then in the
next preparation we poked both of them
but with sharp electrodes in panel C and
found that they burst out of phase with
one another and we also poked known
neurons sharp electrodes and found that
one of the pattern generator neurons vs
IB projects and excites one of these
brand new neurons so all of this in the
space of one or two preparations that
illustrates the power of optical
recording to characterize brand new
systems and learn a lot rapidly another
thing we can do is step up from single
neuron perspective to the full set of
neurons panel a shows a nap Lizzie up
Edel gangly and ready for optical
recording there's the animal below it
panel B shows our acquisition of optical
data during the rhythmic locomotion
motor program that that animal undergoes
after an aversive stimulus paddle C
shows the similarity matrix we generate
from that meaning every neuron is
plotted against every other neuron with
respect to the degree to which they're
firing correlates with each other so you
get cells that fire together in red in
that case then you can do unsupervised
community detection clustering to reveal
the functional ensembles and here we
found right away in this right away and
the first prep we tried it in here that
there's a group that fires in panel D
with a phase lag so they say come on
later in later later later as they pass
it off to each other and there's another
group that fires in the bottom half of
that all simultaneously
annalee is an example of a network graph
you can produce immediately from your
similarity matrix in which you can see
how similarly in time different neurons
fire with respect to one another and
panel def shows that you can then map
those right back onto the gangly now the
title of this slide says you can do it
in minutes rather than years you can do
this false of an analysis within the
Contin the time frame of a single
preparation and even go back to the
preparation and start poking neurons
that you discovered this way the tools
that by which we developed for these
analysis methods were published in a
neuron paper by a graduate student
Angelo Bruno and
computational colleague in England mark
humphreys we're part of the the main
parts of that study when we go to the
next slide we're gonna just advance to
the next slide you can look at neurons
with respect to single individuals or
record lots of nerves at the same time
as you can see on this diagram this uh
spike train diagram on the left this is
a 20-minute optical recording using a
voltage-sensitive dye we can do that
with with absorbance dyes there's little
toxicity little bleaching and so here's
a long 20 minute recording of a nap
Lizzie escaped a motor program the very
beginning there's a gallop phase
followed by a prolonged crawl phase
rhythmically bursting now you could look
at that with respect we did in the last
slide for how to neurons assemble
themselves in two different functional
ensembles or you can you can look at it
with respect to the full population and
it's often the case that the variability
among individual neurons is quite high
that's high dimensionality data but if
you if you pull back and do a
dimensionality reduction and look at the
same data you're looking at the full
population and when you do that here
we're plotting on the right side of this
figure a the top three principal
components of variability in this
preparation of the full population and
you can see you can readily distinguish
the gallop which is the initial winding
phase of that transitioning into the
crawl and by studying this in depth and
using some novel mathematics with our
countries we were able to determine that
this was an example of a spiral
attractor in the first one seen in
biology finally what I'm showing you
some Berga data so the animals in the
upper left is brains bend out and
stained with the voltage-sensitive dye
in the next panel to the right we place
it above the photodiode array shown in
the third panel and then to the right
the upper right panel is showing the
neurons that were active during that
blue minute recording so it's a
photodiode array it can tell you
immediately where these neurons are
located and so we mapped the activity
right onto the ganglion the lower left
is the two-minute recording of all the
spike trains of these 55 neurons next to
that is the is the network graph showing
their their their firing relationships
to
they're in correlation space the further
apart they are the more dissimilar they
are in firing the panel to the right of
that is the after functional clustering
so that we can see the ensemble groups
and then those are plotted in the right
hand panel right onto the ganglion with
numbers for every neuron in the traces
and colors representing their functional
ensemble membership you can immediately
see for example whether the given
function ensemble is located in a
different region as a cluster two into
the two individuals in my group that are
working on this with me are Evan Hill
and the top photo and Jeff Brown in the
lower photo finally I just wanted to get
back to intracellular recordings so one
of the things optical recording might do
is identify neurons of interest to
pursue perhaps mechanistically and learn
more back to sharps and so this is an
intact animal intracellular recording
preparation in a neighbor Jia I've
circled in the lower left picture where
the brain is located the upper left the
upper left picture then shows the brain
exposed surgically in the intact animal
the upper right shows it so close that
you can see many individual neurons and
there's an intracellular recording
showing that we can actually do these
intact animal recording experiments in
Berga and I would have to say that this
the group nature of this 5p i uo 1 has
been fantastically helpful for us we
have weekly zoo meetings we also have
invited speakers and we have offline
conversations after the zoo meetings
everything's recorded so that we look
again at each other's presentations
weekly and see I'd get down details so
that I can learn about preparation of
transgenic animals for example or
interact better with the computational
colleague that'll be speaking shortly
next what I want to do is hand this off
to Jeff Lichtman who is pairing with his
colleagues the e/m level connectome of
Burgas brain as bill just mentioned one
of the jobs that we are trying to
accomplish in berea is to do
connectomics of this animal neck tommix
is a mapping of the wiring diagram using
high-resolution serial electron
microscopy this is a challenging
goal tasks I'm going to go through some
of the steps here
our goal is an odd audacious I would say
we want to produce a complete synaptic
circuit of this animal and how we're
going to do this is a series of steps
that have to be done
beginning with fixing the animal to
preserve the ultra structure then
staining the animal with heavy metals
that are visible in the electron
microscope and then imaging the animal
using electron microscopy and imaging a
well-preserved and well staines specimen
the cirrie electron microscopy requires
lots of expertise and in this case
Brandon pressure from Paul's lab and
Richard shellac from my lab have been
leading the charge in doing this those
are the first three steps then once the
images are acquired they have to be
stitched together because you can't take
the whole section in one image there at
this resolution you have to stitch many
sections together many tiles together to
make a section and then you have to
align one section to the other these are
computationally challenging steps in the
process and then ultimately one wants to
reconstruct from those stack of images
the circuit and that is so large it
can't be done entirely manually so we
have to train a machine learning
algorithm by generating ground truth so
those are the three main steps and this
has got many technical challenges that
have to be overcome especially because
we're using an organism about which
there's very little serial electron
microscopy so first of all we have to
figure out how to get good fixation we
have thanks to the efforts of Brandon
know that for smaller samples we can use
high pressure freezing as a way of
preserving the samples quality and for
whole adults he has generated a nice
protocol now where we just do immersion
fixation or
Dunc fixing a whole animals that also
looks good the next thing is you have to
stain the animal you have to get the
heavy metals all the way in the heavy
metal especially is osmium the most
important agent for contrast and
electron microscopy and we use para gala
which enhances the quality of these
images and the staining now is excellent
imaging we have mastered it's pretty
much the same for all samples so there's
no real new innovations in the imaging
side here and then we have to generate
enough ground truth that we can learn
how to do with machine learning
automatic wiring and we take an
advantage as you'll hear me say of
transfer learning from another animal
the octopus which has given us a good
way of getting wiring diagrams and then
finally there has to be good
segmentation related to that ground
truth and good agglomeration and those
last steps we've also made good progress
on I want to just show you some of these
early steps the image acquisition
pipeline is fixation staining then we
have to infiltrate the specimen with a
very hard resin that allows us to cut it
and we trim that resin block then we
typically take a x-ray three-dimensional
image using a micro CT device then that
assures us that the stain is excellent
then we section the sample at very high
resolution 30 nano meter sections so
they're very thin sections and then we
cut those sections and put them on a
wafer we cut strips of those sections
but the model wafer and we image the
wafers and then a whole second pipeline
goes on which is related to processing I
talked already about stitching and
alignment and segmentation this is what
a block with a little you can see at the
very top of the cylinder of resin
there's a little object in there
suburbia and then we trim these blocks
so that just the Berea is sitting up you
know pedestal basically and then that is
what we cut into many different sections
we collect the sections on tape and put
them on a silicon wafer so you have a
bunch of sections sitting on a silicon
wafer in here you see 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
maybe 9 strips and each strip has maybe
20 little sections 33 nanometer sections
of Berg eeeh each one is outlined in
green this outlining is part of the
process of mapping the wafer so that the
electron microscope only images those
particular sections and not the whole
wafer otherwise it would take way too
long from those sections it's like a
confluence tack in light microscopy we
have a three dimensional data stack once
they're aligned and I'm going to show
you next a movie of this and it's going
to be a movie of just one part of Haber
Ghia it's a ganglion called the Rhino
for ganglion it's about a quarter of a
millimeter by 1/5 of a millimeter by 80
microns and we serially sectioned it at
33 nanometers and took approximately
fifty nine hundred sections and those
sections were aligned and I'm going to
now play for you a movie of this
particular writer for ganglion this is a
serial reconstruction of the Rhino four
ganglia and we're going all the way
through 6,000 sections 33 nanometers
apart to the top and back through the
ganglion and from the bottom the bottom
is where the input comes from the nose
the cells are the large cells on the
outside and we're going to end right
with the connection of this ganglion
into the cerebral floor okay so as you
see at the end of the movie we have this
little connective between the right of
four ganglion and the cerebral pleural
ganglion you can't tell at this
resolution what's in that connective it
was really quite surprising when we
looked at that connective at high
resolution which is the resolution these
images were taken to see what was
actually connecting this Rhino for
ganglion which is considered part of the
sensory system for odors and the
cerebral plural where a lot of central
processing goes on let me just zoom up
on that little writer for ganglion I
think you can appreciate in this image
that there are a bunch of little circles
everywhere these circles are
cross-sections of processes that are
running between these ganglia I'm going
to zoom up on this little area here in
the next slide and the dark object you
see sort of with tendrils in the middle
is a glial cell and it's just completely
surrounded by thousands of very very
small processes many more than one might
expect in fact the total number of
processes in this connective exceeds the
number of neurons we imagined we're in
Verbier altogether so there's clearly
lots of processing going on that until
we looked at this was not so clear all
these processes that are passing between
these two ganglia are not the same if I
go to another region where this dotted
rectangle is you see some of the
processes appear lighter than others if
we zoom up on this you can see three
different categories actually of
processes passing between the two
ganglia some of them are quite large
cross-sections
many of them are small and some of them
the ones on the upper right quadrant of
this image are extremely small and
separated by some space between the
individual processes by tracing through
the images of this connective we realize
these are processes that come from the
periphery and just pass right through
the Rhine of four ganglion on their way
into the cerebral floral ganglion we
still don't know what they are but this
is one of the reasons connectomics is so
powerful because it forces you to
confront things you might not have
expected before the next thing we have
to do once we have images like this is
to generate ground truth you can see
that if a human being tried to analyze
every one of these processes it would
take a very very long time and so what
we do is use a tool called fast that was
generated by Daniel Berger works with us
in this lab that allows one to color in
individual processes and section after
section in the same color and this is
ground truth training for algorithms and
you can train you can not train but in
this case of color in many individual
processes and you can color in the
extracellular space a different color in
this case a light purple once you have
ground truth then the next step is to
use machine learning to generate
automatic wiring and this is work that
has been spearheaded by your own mirror
vish with the help of elisa cover you
know and Daniel Berger who made fast so
vast is the tool on the bottom of those
three images that does the coloring in
and then ELISA and your own made
membrane which is a program that allows
one to process the training data that
came from vast and the data is stored on
a hard drive and this machine learning
approach where you use ground truth and
generate a sort of inference of where
connect where it just R can be corrected
I've asked over time someone can very
quickly get to a pretty good result I'll
show you an example of this results here
in Berga we are now already about 95%
accurate here is a piece of Boerne aware
the yellow are extracellular areas and
the outlines of cells are in a sort of
bluish color and the important point to
see is that there's very little yellow
inside cells and there's very little
purple in the extracellular space it's
good but it's not perfect if we look at
a larger area one would expect the pink
stuff only to be outside and the green
color only to be inside but there are
many places the cell with the nucleus in
the upper right you see a lot of pink
inside the cell and so there still is a
poor generalization of this algorithm
and we need more very grand truth a lot
more ground truth to get a better result
we'd like to get that result up at least
another two percentage points and as we
were thinking about this your own
suggested the following that because we
had already in a different project been
working on octopus maybe octopus which
is the right most mollusk in this family
tree of mollusks is distantly related to
gastropods and new tube ranks which is
the second from the left is what a Bergy
is perhaps octopus could provide us with
ground truth since we already have a lot
of ground truth from octopus that could
be transferred as knowledge for our
segmentation of new tube ranks let's
just show you this picture here which I
think at first sight just looks like a
picture of maybe a Bergy actually it's
two pictures right next to each other
right there these are two different
organisms that are hundreds of millions
of years apart and evolution this is the
Rhino for ganglion in berea and this is
the vertical
of an octopus octopus vulgaris that came
from Flavia Vidal and many hikers lab in
work that they've been doing with us and
so with transfer learning it's possible
to take what lessons we learned in the
vertical lobe and apply that to Verbier
tissue and this is a somewhat
complicated graph but I think the trend
is obvious that as one does more and
more iterations of training in this case
several thousand when finally gets to a
point where the accuracy is 97% and this
is quite excellent now here is some
Verbier where the cells are well
segmented the objects are outlines are
found nicely put in some extra cellular
space here and this gives us great
confidence that we will be able to get
very nice segmentation of objects at
this point so what remains to be done is
now take these proof of principles that
have worked and now do a whole Bergy of
rain and the first thing is to get good
fixation of an entire brain we have done
that way we have a brain that looks
quite good now we have several of them
actually and we can assess the tissue
quality of these brains in micro CT
images of para gall osmium stained over
via and and I just now show you a micro
CT image of the whole grain of birtija
which is ready to be worked on near
future next up for us is to do an entire
Bergy of cereal am here you see the
micro CT going through an entire animal
that's been well stained we will be
starting to cut this animal in a few
weeks so having all this segmented data
will be treasure trove for understanding
one hopes the circuitry inside
this small mollusk but it will be very
difficult to do without the help of
people with men much greater
quantitative skills than biologists like
me mathematicians are necessary to look
at these data and find graph structures
in the connectomics and this is going to
tell you a little bit about what kinds
of work is going on on the quantitative
side of analysis of birtija next hello
i'm vince Lozinski i'm at university of
maryland and i'm going to talk a little
bit about some of the work we've done to
build sort of the machinery to new
statistical network inference on the
Bergy of connectome my work in general
is in the area of statistical network
inference developing sort of model novel
models methods and algorithms to sort of
run classical statistical machinery on
sort of non classical data which
networks are a nice example of and the
motivation for the work and sort of the
motivation when I initially started
talking with Paul about this project is
this idea that the connectome the brain
graph itself is a scaffolding that
allows us to tie together a lot of the
different efforts on our team and so the
way I view this is we're gonna develop
these models methods and algorithmic
primitives for doing Network inference
or but XI learning on the connectome but
it's the connectome plus and it's the
connectome plus the voltage intuitive
dye recordings that are coming out of
bill's lab plus the behavioral data
coming out of pauls group plus the
transgenic stuff coming out of DVS lab
so the the connectome will be some a
bridge that allows us to tie together
these discs yes so the three aspects of
the work I'll touch on that work or
tackling now or essentially models
methods and algorithms so one of the key
appease to our approach is developing
novel Network models to capture the
structure of the Bergy a connectome
we're motivated by this idea of a
connectome code it's a model for
characterizing the information how the
infirmary
from brain activity in the genome is
represented in the brain by the
connections between them
morphological objects and this model for
formula formalism allows us to frame
neuro scientific questions as
statistical inference tasks like
classification like hypothesis testing I
mean it allows us to sort of build a
general machinery that can then tackle
these questions and so here's an example
of some of the work we've done on the
drosophila mushroom body connect them
from a paper from Eckler eichler at all
where we had we tried a bunch fitting a
bunch of existing parsimonious Network
models and it didn't capture the
structure of the data didn't fit the
data well so we had to develop new novel
latent structure models to sort of
capture the neuro scientifically
significant structure and the resulting
connectome code again and elucidated
biologically relevant neuronal
properties and what we're gonna be
working on developing the same thing
same types of analyses for the birdie at
connect to them as well the second key
to our approach is developing new
methods here I'll focus on methods for
Network comparison but sort of methods
for Network inference writ large so
we're working on developing novel
methods for comparing both structurally
and statistically networks structural
comparisons via
novel graph matching or graph alignment
methods and now and leaving that leading
to sort of novel brat classification
methods classifying graphs both at the
grass level and at the the neuron level
but also statistical comparisons that we
can sort of fill up new hypothesis
testing methods to see if
distributionally we can tell one
connectome instantiation with features
on it from another and here's an example
of some of the type of work that we can
do we had a partially reconstructed
drosophila medulla connectome and we
developed them at the dis imal taneous
lis cluster the neurons you can see
there's the sort of flowchart the left
is what we saw from the connectome it's
this sort of unstructured network if you
squint a little bit you can see these
little colored boxes in the
top right those are the clusters that we
found where we're able to group neurons
into these sort of communities that are
based on a similarity of how they're
connecting to the rest of the graph and
then we're able to classify these
communities into network motifs and
figure out sort of is there repeated
structure that's going across the brain
and in berga this will allow us to
detect and classify motifs within the
connection itself we're also working on
sort of taking these ideas of new models
and new methods and translating them
into actually a new statistical
machinery or new algorithmic primitives
for tackling these classical questions
in this non classical setting so
algorithms were focused a lot on
algorithms for a multi scale multigraph
inference so things like time series or
change point detection when you have
time series of networks for things like
multi scale testing we were able to
determine significant changes both at
the network level but also sort of what
individual neurons are driving that
change so we have we've run this on some
light field microscopy data from
whole-brain zebrafish neuronal activity
and we had a time series these led to a
time series of graphs that we were able
to then do things like change point
detection for using manifold learning
methodologies to discover where there
was a stimulus or where the there was a
firing in the brain that was an anomaly
and the multi scale methods allowed us
not only to do that at the brain level
but to uncover which neurons behaviors
correlated with this change and in the
burgh 'ya we can do this same type of
thing with the voltage-sensitive dye
recordings coming out of bill's group we
can transform these things as bill was
mentioning into correlation networks and
that can lead to things like neuron
clustering and change point neuron
clustering based on sort of grouping
similar grouping neurons who are firing
and similar ways to each other but it
also if you sort of look at the voltage
sensitive data recording as a and sort
of discretize the time you can view this
as leading to a time series of networks
and what we can try to do is sort of
build these correlation
works and try to identify when the
activity said when the first sort of
anomalous activity or when in this case
there was a nerve stim time series of
networks and also try to figure out what
neurons are corresponding to this here
we see a very simple two-dimensional
representation of each of the neurons in
the brain so there's six panels the
all-black panel in the top left those
are just two-dimensional representations
of the nerve of the nerves in the
voltage-sensitive dye recording the next
panel shows when the stimulus was being
applied when there was the nerve skin
the red points are now the new
two-dimensional representation and the
blue lines are connecting the old
two-dimensional representation with the
new and you can see that there's a
significant change in the neuronal
activity
the third shows the time frame after the
stem and you can see the nerves are sort
of reregulate anat exactly to the same
structure they had before but roughly
the same and then in the in the
remaining panels there's education at
consecutive time points without a stem
and there's not a whole lot of change
occurring and so we're building these
novel time series methods that allow us
to classify from a statistical the
specify sort of statistically
significant change points in the time
series but also identify what neurons
behaviors are corresponding to this time
series to try to understand what nerve
what neuronal X what neurons behaviors
are sort of being stimulated or
corresponding to different activities
when we have behavior corresponding to
the recording what the connectome allows
us to do as well though it allows us to
compare across different
voltage-sensitive dye recordings so in
the voltage-sensitive dye we might know
what neurons are being recorded but that
might change from animal to animal or
from sample to sample and the connection
will allow us to sort of infer what's
missing and compare across these
recordings that might not exactly be
from the same neurons and this is an
exciting thing that connectome enables
us to do just as an example
so we're working on models methods and
algorithms to sort of tie the connectome
this this statistical object to the
features and to the behaviors into the
information coming out of the rest of
the group and it's been from a as a math
statistician it's been incredibly
interesting to sort of a learning about
the biology as we go but also sort of
trying to understand the biologically
significant in the biological relevance
of the findings that were able to
produce from a purely maths at
perspective so I'll next pass it over to
DeeDee Lyons she's working on creating
genetic tools to move discovery forward
all right thanks Vince I'm Dierdre Lyons
I'm from UC San Diego and I'm going to
be talking about developing functional
genomics tools to use to study the brain
in Berga for this project so as Paul
already mentioned and the adults the
brain has identifiable neurons and here
you see this beautiful confocal image
again showing individual neurons being
stained by two neurotransmitters and
more interested in is trying to look at
these types of identified neurons and
their activity in the living animal as
opposed to stained and
immunohistochemistry process embryos or
fixed embryos or even dissected brains
being measured outside of the body so my
project part of this project is to make
genetically encoded biosensors for
instance a G camp that would allow us to
look at the behavior and activity of
these neurons and their synapses
in the living embryo and also be able to
understand and learn about new neurons
that we might not have already had
markers for such as these
neurotransmitters as well as looking for
smaller cells that maybe are harder to
image by the calcium dyes or not able to
distinguish between in our the other
types of imaging techniques that we're
using and adding the genetic molecular
transcriptomic markers for all of the
cells in the brain and understand how
they're different from one another so to
do that the real key is to be able to
get
says to the animals to make transgenic
animals you need to be able to access
this entire life history stages it needs
to happen in a time frame that's usable
for people to do manipulations and then
see the effect and have genetics and we
also need to be able to look at the cell
type expression of genes and that
requires knowledge of how the brain is
specified during development as well as
having genomic tools like transcript
tones single-cell seek attack seek and
other types of molecular data which
we're also working on so the first and
most important aspects that Paul
mentioned was that this animal is able
to be grown in the lab which is very
useful so here on the left you're seeing
a dorsal view of the adult which you've
seen before and in the center now is a
ventral view and you can see that this
animal is laying an egg case of
thousands hundreds of thousands of eggs
and these are hermaphroditic animals and
so once the egg case are laid they're
actually fertilized eggs and then you're
seen here if we left them in a dish to
let them grow up I'm zooming in here on
the right panel to show you the little
village or larval stages that are inside
these eggs cases and individual capsules
so first we needed to have a
developmental time course to try and
understand these organisms and to see
how efficient it was to grow them in the
lab and then we need to develop
techniques to access their embryos and
deliver reagents so here I'm starting on
the top left with an egg mass these are
the hundreds of embryos that have been
laid together by a single individual
after meeting and at t0 for instance you
can see the fertilized egg here which we
called the zygote and we have a very no
regular time course for all these
developmental stages so it by j-1 you
have the embryos undergo very
stereotyped spiral cleavage program
which is typical for mollusks and other
animals rule ages of them like annelids
by day ten you have the villager larval
stage so this is actually not a swimming
stage in this particular species it's
all encapsulated but in other species
this is the dispersal stage and you can
already see tiny eye spots and in fact
these neuter brains have shells and in
development even though they lose the
ability to make shells as adults by day
20 are seen here on the bottom left the
process of metamorphosis so the animal
now
has changed his body claim from the
villager larval stage choose something
that's more worm-like and it's actually
here crawling out of its shell so it
abandons the shell and crawls away
looking for for food by day 13 day 40
you can start to see the development of
the juveniles into something that looks
like the nudibranch and then by day 45
you have something that looks like a
young adult which is basically
indistinguishable from a much older
adult except that they have more dorsal
appendages and they're larger and by
about age 60 they will be able to
reproduce again in the egg so it's a
pretty fast generation time and we have
access to all these stages of
development so what we really want to
understand as I mentioned is how the
brain develops so that previous slide
wasn't just feel but here you're showing
I'm showing on the left some cartoons of
the size differences that we're getting
when you go from that hatched juvenile
to something more like a the young adult
and not only is the whole body changing
and growing but so is the brain and so
we want to know how similar are the is
the brain over these developmental time
course is when does do these cell types
become different from one another how
does the brain incorporate extra cells
and neurons as it grows when did they
become specified and of course
throughout this whole process as the
brain is being modified the animal has
to behave and avoid predators buying
food so we would love to also understand
how the behavioral process changes over
development with this very stereotyped
brain and then we know that when the
adults so then what my lab started to do
is to take some of these same markers
and look at the expression of those
antibodies in the juvenile stages of the
intact animals so not dissected brains
like I'm showing here on the right so
what we did is to develop an antibody
staining protocol for these juvenile
stages on the left I'm showing you a new
Marquis or di see image of one of those
tiny little hatchlings the ones that
metamorphosis and just as they starts
with look worm-like in the central panel
you can see an overlay of Dappy to just
show where all the neurons are as well
as the SCP and the firm if reminds
things you saw in the adult you can see
that the brain is there between the two
eye spots on the far left those two
black spots are the
and we can see that there is a similar
oddly similar arrangement of the ganglia
in the adult already in this juvenile
stage and this makes sense because these
animals are going to lock them out find
each other hunt feed avoid predators
just the way the adults are and so then
with the next step of what we really
want to understand is we can't really
understand exactly how this juvenile
brain organization and the adult brain
are related to one another
exactly unless we have the bona fide
thing that links these two is is lineage
tracing so if we can mark parts of the
brain in the juvenile or even in the
larval phase and let those cells grow up
and see how they metamorphose and I
mature into the adult brain then we can
actually correlate cell types between
the left and the right images so at the
moment since these are fixed dead
samples it could be that a
neurotransmitter is on in one cell type
and then over development it gets turned
off and comes up on another cell type
and so even though we see magenta and
green dots we don't yet know whether
those are actually the same cell types
but the point from this data is that we
can see that the organization already
exists so then the next thing we have to
do was also not only important for
lineage tracing but for the
transformation to try and get
transgenics to work you need to be able
to deliver reagents into the eggs and
embryos and so for that I'm taking an
advantage of techniques that I've used
in other organisms so as people already
said we've seen a number of species of
mollusk discussed already soap Lygia
Tritonia other types of animals other
gastropods then these animals all share
very highly stereotyped early cleavage
pattern called spiral cleavage and an
evolutionarily conserved fate map so
what I'm showing on the top left panel
is an embryo of a snail that I use a
marine snail that I use and all of the
cells are are shown here at this stage
and one of the cells is labeled as a 1b
cell so we know for instance that if you
directly
fill that 1b saw with a lineage tracer
and grow up in the next panel at an
organ adenosine stage post gastrulation
you can see that that pink tissue now
lines a specific part of the animal in
the head anterior to the math or stoma
DM which is marked here if you grow
those up to the villager stage you can
see that that pink
tissue has now changed its shape and
migrated now to line the ciliary bands
that allow that villager stage to swim
around in the water column and you can
do that for all of the cells that are in
this embryo as well as even their
daughter cells but we're only marking
the cells that give rise to the head and
the ectoderm in the anterior part of the
embryo so we'd love to do this type of
work for for maria and trying to
understand where the brain comes up from
and it'll be really interesting for us
to see this process post metamorphosis
because for instance in this species
that i work on we never go past this
villager stage to understand where the
adult brain comes from so what we've
developed here are some of the first
steps of doing this type of work in
Burgas you can see that on the labs
bottom panel you can see the same
organization of the early embryo in
berea and we can even identify
particular cells and i'm not labeling
them a b c or d because those denote
knowing where the dorsal ventral
left/right axes are which we have not
determined yet but we will be able to
after we carry out the lineage tracing
then in the center you can see an embryo
that is just the ventral side of the
embryo with a mouth in a similar
position to the one i showed in the
cartoon above it then on the far right
of Villager stage from from the berg and
these embryos on the bottom are fixed
and stained with phalloidin and daffy to
indicate the outline of cells and the
nucleus so what then we need to do is
try and deliver regions just to subsets
of these cells to understand the the
patterns of clones from these cells and
so here is a first example of some sub
lineages that we're doing it's just the
two cell stage so on the left I'm
showing that whole fixed embryo again
and the two other panels are live
embryos where a dextran has been
injected into one of the two cells at
the two soft stage and you can see that
that clone has grown up now that side of
the embryo is many many cells and is
marking the posterior part of the embryo
and the unlabeled part of the embryo
that you can see on the far right and
the D I see would be where the brain
comes from so we're excited to keep on
carrying out this lineage tracing to
understand where these cell types come
from and if we can inject these Dec
strands it means that we can also inject
other reagents like CRISPR Cassadine
reagents reagents for making transgenic
line
and that's what we're working on right
now and also working out trance from
transcriptomic and single cells seek
datasets so that we can find enhancers
that drive three agents such as gcamp
into particular cell types in the brain
and with that I will just say that it's
been really exciting to work with this
group of people and especially as I
mentioned the work I do in development
in malice never is actually linked to
specific behaviors and not some things
that the adults do so it's like very
exciting to be for me to learn about
these processes and be able to connect
the molecules all the way to behavior
with one project and with that I was
handed back to Paul so finish up so as
you've heard that this collaboration
among the these researchers at different
universities that was enabled by the
brain initiative has really been a major
boost to our research we've been able to
take an animal from zero to sixty really
quickly because of the expertise that
these skilled researchers have had and
also in collaboration with other people
Joe Bergin mark humphreys and ed Boyden
who is joined our group as well what
we've done is created tools for an
animal that nobody's worked on before
but based on our knowledge that we
gained from studying other neuter banks
and I think that this is a way forward
and comparative neuroscience to be able
to not be stuck with the same five
standard organisms but to start to look
more broadly at the diversity of animals
to answer questions that are best
answered and to answer questions
regarding the diversity of life in the
diversity of the way that nervous
systems are producing behavior so thank
you for listening and we hope you
enjoyed the presentation